she's an Oscar nominee tonight for Best
Actress
welcome Halle Halle Berry
without sound you wouldn't hear the
lyrics this is what oscar-winning
lyricist Alan and Marilyn Bergman had to
say about achievements in sound and
sound editing sound is the sensation
that is due to stimulation it's
transmitted by vibration to the Centers
of the brain if that sounds scientific
oh I can be more specific with your kind
indulgence please allow me to explain a
smack a whack a quack a creek a spike a
shriek a punch a crunch a munch a breeze
a wheeze up to a sneeze a thump a bump a
thump a snap a tap a clap a splash of
smash a crash a peck or whack a Schreck
the sound editor collects and perfects
dialogue music and effects to muse to
amazed scared to excite it takes talent
and time to get it all just right they
mix they fix they create they record
that is why they deserve the academy
award for best achievement in sound the
nominees are Vasa an RD young Larry SH
and Jean ooh man ski for Emily
Michael Minkler Myron nettinger
and Kris Munroe for Black Hawk Down
Christopher boys Michael semanek Gethin
Creek and Hammond piece for the Lord of
the Rings the Fellowship of the Ring
Andy Nelson and a Belle mer Roger savage
and Goethe six for Moulin Rouge Kevin
O'Connell Greg P Russell and Peter J
Devlin for Pearl Harbor
and the Oscar goes to Michael Winkler
Myron nutty berry Kris Munroe Black Hawk
Down
having the award nomination for Michael
Miller ii for chris monroe and the first
for Myron nipper
first Oscars
that's like gladly I guess don't drop it
ah this is really something on behalf of
my colleagues my Renetta GaN Kris Munroe
I express how proud we are to be
associated with this film and the very
honorable men whose actions it depicts
and we extend our gratitude to all the
men in the armed forces who are putting
themselves at similar risks every day in
order to ensure our freedoms
we owe this moment to the precision and
passion of Ridley Scott pho scalia and
pear Hallberg in the leadership of jerry
bruckheimer and joe roth and revolution
studios
personally I believe that in everyone's
life there there's a person that takes
you to another level and introduces you
to greater possibilities my wife has
taken me and introduced me to the
extraordinary Thank You Patti
for best achievement in sound editing
the nominees are Gary Raj - and Michael
Silver's for monsters incorporated
George waters the second and Christopher
Boyce for Pearl Harbor
and the Oscar goes to George waters the
second and Christopher boys Pearl Harbor
thank you very much to everyone in the
Academy for this great honor we share
these awards with many different
individuals
first of all Jerry Bruckheimer and
Michael Bay thank you both for your many
years of loyal support and for
operations offering us unique
opportunities and sound Walt Disney
Studios Wayne of us to sound
re-recording mixer is Kevin O'Connell
and Greg Russell for the great job they
always do everyone in the Cary Grant
theater Pat Samson Peter Devlin our
entire crew and my wife Shannon
Ethan van Duren bow boarders Terry
Dorman Victoria Martin Chris Welch all
the editors and assistants Skywalker
Sound my wife Molly my mom Katherine my
sons Tyler Daniel and Aaron we'd also
like to acknowledge all the veterans
from Pearl Harbor and from Wars all the
way around the world thank you